[Music]
your tickets from any major league game
you still need an id
of course you know to do that um
airlines same thing and you do need an
id to fly
i do love people this thing this is
voter suppression you're right that's
because minorities don't get on planes
don't go to the doctor don't drive cars
and don't and you know what else
requires an id mike
getting the [ __ ] vaccine requires an
id
they don't just give it to you you have
to give them an id for that
uh but whatever hey you know what i
don't care anymore
uh i love you anymore america sorry
yeah this is this is great speaking of
the vaccine this is a [ __ ] terrorist
you saw this
no oh this is fun uh
check this out clear to them that the
vaccine is the ticket back to
pre-pandemic life
and the window hey you know what the
ticket is to pre-pandemic life
the [ __ ] constitution suck a dick the
ticket back to pre-pandemic life
and the window to do that is really
narrowing i mean you were mentioning
chris about how
all these states are reopening they're
reopening at a hundred percent
and we have a very narrow window to tie
reopening
policy to vaccination status because
otherwise if everything is reopened
then what's the carrot going to be how
are we going to incentivize people to
actually get the vaccine
so that's why i think the cdc and the
obama administration needs to come out a
lot bolder and say
if you're vaccinated you can do all
these things here all these freedoms
that you have
because otherwise people are going to go
out and enjoy these freedoms anyway
oh no oh god the horror [ __ ]
the horror look at all these freedoms
you have
the carrot you're [ __ ]
nothing but cattle to these people
the witch people elites but you know
it's so funny too because the 24-hour
news network
is like the greatest tool of propaganda
that they've ever had but it's also like
their undoing because
when you let these people just talk
when you let them just fill air time
with their genuine thoughts
it's pretty terrifying the things
look i'm every once in a while like i
don't like playing things twice but i'm
playing this again
it's clear to them that the vaccine is
the ticket back to pre-pandemic life
and the window to do that is really
narrowing i mean you were mentioning
chris about how
all these states are reopening they're
reopening at 100
and we have a very narrow window to tie
reopening
policy to vaccination status because
otherwise if everything is reopened
then what's the carrot going to be how
are we going to incentivize people to
actually get the vaccine
so that's why i think the cdc and the
bond administration needs to come out a
lot bolder and say
if you're vaccinated you can do all
these things here all these freedoms
that you have
because otherwise people are going to go
out and enjoy these freedoms anyway
also maybe get a less a woman with less
of an
asian accent yeah tell me why i can't
live my life because of an
asian pandemic all of these free
they look man they really think they
give it to you
they they really think that they're they
give it to you they give you what you're
what they believe you're entitled to
it's insane
they think your freedom comes from them
they do they believe they hold your
freedom in their hands
it's you let me tell you something
you're free
you you should be free as a human being
to do whatever the [ __ ] you want
at the beginning of this and i remember
you and i covered this at the beginning
as we got a lot of [ __ ] too
when we were saying like we shouldn't be
locking down there's a lot of people
that have apologized i mean you guys
were right this was [ __ ]
but remember there was even our fans
people that are you know
freedom people libertarian leaning they
were like saying like no man this is
serious we need a lockdown okay
we need to lock down don't worry it's a
couple weeks sorry i don't want my
grandma to die
this isn't about your grandma dying
anymore this is exactly what merch and i
were saying and you go back and listen
to it
we're saying at the very beginning of
this we were saying
they're going to take your freedoms away
and they're not going to give them back
and they're not going to give them back
because the carrot
the cat i'm not a horse you dumb [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you more like a horse than i do
yeah the [ __ ]
these [ __ ] people they take
everything from you
and then they sell it back to you with
interest
that's what they did they took your
freedoms away
and now they've raised the price on them
which freedoms
um it's in the name they should be free
are now coming back to you and they're
selling it to you at a [ __ ] price
and saying here you go you want it take
this shot
and they [ __ ] hate states like
florida and like [ __ ] texas
and south dakota that said [ __ ] you
we're opening
santa santas came out again and doubled
down and saying i am going to have an
executive order
saying that there will be no vaccine
passports and businesses are not allowed
businesses are not allowed to check your
vaccine status
for you to be able to use your services
and all these people
that were like saying oh you know this
government should mandate businesses to
make you wear a mask saying like oh
excuse me
private businesses shouldn't be mandated
they [ __ ] should
and you want to know why they should
because there's [ __ ]
hippa laws that that there are laws that
say businesses cannot ask you
your medical status on anything to
provide you
services so if you want to
bake the cake bigot then give my
unvaccinated ass
whatever i want if i'm giving you money
pick a [ __ ] lane
you can't have it both ways but they're
getting bold
and they're going on cnn and you could
even tell the coma over here like i
don't like homo but you can even tell
that his face is like um
you're saying the quiet part out loud
what are you doing
you don't say that [ __ ] out loud you
[ __ ] nut job
these [ __ ] peep the carrot that's
what they
think of you and i love that she's doing
it
i love that she's this outraged and
disgusted it
just shows to express it on the show of
the guy that
had coveted and was still just like
going out
just completely
look here's some little here's some
little freedoms you could have if you
get vaccinated
the guy there you go the guy who show
you on it had covid and was out talking
to his neighbors
yeah fighting not talking fighting
wanting a fist
so [ __ ] these people man honestly [ __ ]
these people